while people in the Panhandle are
returning home to see what if anything
is left some communities were flattened
while others were mostly spared it will
take weeks to clean up and assess the
damage and months or even years to
rebuild Nicky batiste
is in Tallahassee after a first-hand
look at the devastation Nicky good
morning good morning here in Tallahassee
we are seeing some damage like this
trees down and power out yesterday we
were an hour away in Bristol where the
damage is even more severe we went with
people heading home for the first time
since the hurricane hit after hunkering
down in safe places and they were
nervous to see what they would find
well my clothes are in there and the
dresses but they're all messed up
peeking into her bedroom for their first
time since hurricane Michael destroyed
it four-year-old Armani is upset her
pink toys are now covered in debris when
you look in there how do you feel inside
Wow her mother Brittney chamber says
when she first saw the damage to her
home in Bristol she broke down crying
[ __ ] overwhelming come home and find her
home like this as the storm hit she took
her daughter with her to her job as a
caretaker at a nursing home nearby when
she came home her entire street was
littered with downed trees and power
lines that couldn't drive home I had to
literally park my car and walk all the
way here it's just like my heart was
sinking in my stomach
we met chambers after we visited her
neighbor Perla ol Vera it was just
debris everywhere
her house is still standing yes and that
was my relief my house is still standing
we first met Oh Vera and her twin
daughters at a local shelter we all
shared during the hurricane she says she
prayed there that her home and family
would be safe do you think your prayers
were answered yes and like I said up
there like the Lord put his hands on
like Oh Vera Chambers is grateful
despite the damage to her home
materialistic things that can be
replaced as long as I have her this is
everything that matters to me in the
world
all of Liberty County where Bristol is
located is without power the local
electric company has ordered 300 utility
poles to repair downed power lines and
it has no idea exactly when power will
be restored
John Nikki Betty's Thank You Nikki